eleven-year-old Muhammad is still in
pain
[Music]
two weeks after he was pulled from the
rubble of his collapsed home in
Northwest Syria he is among the
thousands of victims of the earthquakes
that had their epicenters in neighboring
turkey
giving appropriate Medical Care to such
patients is complicated because we need
proper supplies and we don't have
anything the injured survivors are many
more than ten thousand across Syria the
majority at least eight thousand are
here in the opposition controlled
Northwest where health facilities are
already under strain due to 12 years of
war giving the medical care appropriate
medical care for such patients is
something which is complicated because
you need everything and the problem is
you don't have anything and some hostels
they will shortage in goals they could
not find ghosts to treat to give to boot
on the wounds for their patients
I hope that donations will come to the
area
Aid and doctors have entered Northwest
Syria but there's been a lack of an
international Disaster Response
hospitals are overwhelmed
and they lack the means to deal with
complex cases this emergency means
patients with chronic illnesses like
kidney failure are not receiving the
necessary treatment I need three
dialysis sessions a week now they've
given me two because they don't have
enough equipment to deal with all the
cases from the earthquake our situation
is very bad here in Northwest Syria we
could die because of the lack of care
many victims suffer from Crush injuries
which could lead to kidney failure
that's why there is a demand for
dialysis well so I was removed from the
rubble after seven hours and I suffered
serious injuries I need kidney dialysis
but it's not available all the time I
can't stand in my own feet on the pain
it's not his only pain
I left my home in Aleppo eight years ago
after we were bombed it was only eight
months ago that I bought a new house now
it's gone
but his greatest loss is his wife and
three children who all died in the ruins
of their new home